whether it was being asked to kiss
someone they found repugnant or simply
being unable to share a set let alone a
scene these stars downright refused to
touch one another
fortunately the stories behind these
feuds can be even more interesting than
the projects themselves
alyson hannigan and jason segel played a
couple on How I Met Your Mother for nine
seasons in that time their characters
Lily and Marshall were an example of a
partnership everyone could aspire to
however Hanigan had to put her foot down
when it came to kissing Segal while
there was no apparent animosity between
them
the former Buffy the Vampire Slayer
actress revealed she simply couldn't
stand the fact that her on-screen
husband was a smoker in real life she
told Digital Spy in 2008 I cannot stand
cigarette smoke it's like kissing an
ashtray and he's trying to be polite by
having gum or mints but it doesn't help
I mean God not only is that a filthy
habit but also tampon however Hannigan
was totally eager to help Seagal kick
his nasty habit as she explained when we
started the pilot for the show he was
like get me to stop smoking I'll be your
best friend so we did this bet where he
would owe me $10 every time he had a
cigarette after the first day he owed me
$200 being in debt to his co-star guts
Eagle to quit cold-turkey
for a while according to Hannigan once
Seagal started getting quote stressed
out he began lighting up again it's
unclear how the duo got over Hannigan's
repulsion for the remainder of the
series but it's possible they kissed a
lot less than the writers were
originally intending fortunately the
actors remained on friendly terms
despite their nicotine dust-up Hollywood
is full of rumors and one of the wildest
dates back to the early 90s when Tupac
Shakur and Janet Jackson were filming
the romantic drama poetic justice as the
rumor goes Jackson refused to kiss her
co-star unless he agreed to get an AIDS
test to keep you ahead up rapper
reportedly refused telling the source
that he took the request as a quote
insult throughout the years both stars
have touched on the subject with Shakur
saying at times that it was absolutely
true however in a 20-19 interview with
The Daily Beast late director John
Singleton explained the whole thing was
supposed to be funny
although Tupac might have missed the
joke he said we were on the set joking
with Janet there and the whole
caste and I was like I don't know if I
want you kissing my actresses I don't
know where your lips have been and it
became a joke and then a joke turned
into some publicity and Tupac was the
only one that was left out of the circle
while singleton later claimed Tupac was
in on the joke the rumor still lingers
with the truth maybe somewhere in the
middle to this day Denzel Washington and
Julia Roberts call each other dear
friends after starring in the 1993 drama
the Pelican brief however it said that
Washington turned down a steamy love
scene between the two of them as he's
reportedly very conscious about how his
fans react to him and interracial scenes
according to Newsweek Washington turned
down the scene out of loyalty to his
female african-american fans the star
reportedly soured to the idea of
interracial love scenes after an
onscreen kiss between him and Mimi
Rogers drew loud boos from black women
and a test screening audience for the
1989 film the mighty Quinn I better go
Washington said black women are not
often seen as objects of desire on film
they have always been my core audience
Roberts confirmed that it was
Washington's idea to cut the scene
although she's sorry she missed out on
the opportunity saying don't I have a
pulse of course I wanted to kiss didn't
sell it was his idea to take the damn
scenes out Charlie Sheen is well known
as one of Hollywood's most notorious
party boys and that's why Lindsey Lohan
was reportedly skeptical about kissing
him multiple times while filming the
2013 comedy scary movie 5 according to a
report from TMZ Lohan was asked to kiss
the actor three times in one scene and
she simply couldn't do it although she's
a notoriously avid party person herself
Lohan was allegedly afraid of Sheen's
spotty history in other words she
thought she might catch something from
Sheen if she kissed him
Lohan allegedly asked for the script to
be changed but it wasn't until the day
of shooting that a body double was
brought in for some of the work
ultimately the two seemed to get along
okay in fact Lohan agreed to a guest
appearance on Sheen's short-lived sitcom
anger management and a plotline that
ended with the two of them in bed
together in 1994 audiences got to see
Julia Roberts start with Nick Nolte and
I love trouble but the rumors about the
love loss between these two actors are
notorious it's
classic example of onset friction and
allegedly the dual refused to even be on
the same set together let alone touch
one another thank you for the mud he's
been quite an addition to my life well
you're very welcome I hope he named him
after me I certainly did
yeah I've grown real attached a little
dick according to a report from the Los
Angeles Times Roberts was irritated by
Nolte's machismo on set and he was
reportedly so annoyed by her attitude
that he would heighten his machismo
around her just to wind her up a bit by
the end of the film it said that duo
couldn't even be on set together without
tempers flaring forcing producers to use
body doubles for most scenes if that
sounds like the kind of thing that would
lead to a bad movie that's because it is
a lot of the critiques at the time had
to do with the lack of chemistry between
the two stars as well as a slew of other
behind the scenes gripes Roberts
admitted that Nolte can be quote
completely charming and very nice
however she also claimed that he was
quote completely disgusting as the
actress put it he's going to hate me for
saying this but he seems to go out of
his way to repel people as for Nolte the
actor responded to Roberts statement
saying it's not nice to call someone
disgusting but she's not a nice person
everyone knows that it's no wonder these
two actors had no desire to touch each
other chances are they might have killed
one another Game of Thrones fans may be
surprised to learn that the characters
Cersei Lannister and Serb Ron of the
Blackwater never actually appeared
together despite their characters almost
exclusively showing up alongside Jaime
and Tyrion Lannister and the reason
behind that has to do with broken hearts
long before heading to Westeros Lena
Headey and Jerome Flynn appeared in the
early 90 series soldier soldier and they
were linked romantically in the early
2000s but according to a 2014 report in
the Telegraph a source claims that he
and Flynn had a very real breakup that
left them no longer on speaking terms he
D reportedly asked the producers to
carefully orchestrate it so they never
had to share a set at the same time the
conflict was artfully handled for the
most part with a few glimpses of drama
here and there such as the season 7
meeting in King's Landing when Bronn
offhandedly says he'd rather go have a
drink than be present for the biggest
political discussion the realm had ever
seen
but you mean go have a drink and while
the fancy folks talking sadly it's
unclear what exactly happened to make
the breakup so tumultuous as the Sun
reports both stars kept it under wraps
and no one from the show nor HBO has
ever commented on it now that the series
is all wrapped up and their characters
are in no danger of sharing the screen
together curious fans may never know
what caused the couple to fall apart
while Dwayne Johnson and Vin Diesel
weren't asked to touch each other often
during The Fast and the Furious
franchise fans likely won't be seeing a
rematch of their epic throwdown from
Fast Five which saw the two hulking
figures fight each other through literal
concrete walls after The Rock made his
debut in the fifth installment at the
Vin Diesel led series things reportedly
turned sour off screen while filming the
fate of furious Johnson posted a cryptic
message on Instagram that he later
deleted and which fans assumed he was
calling out diesel however things got
official when he confirmed a rolling
stone that he and diesel had friction on
Seth he said Ben and I had a few
discussions including an important
face-to-face in my trailer and what I
came to realize is that we have a
fundamental difference in philosophies
on how we approach moviemaking and
collaborating it took me some time but
I'm grateful for that clarity whether we
work together again or not Johnson later
confirmed that he and diesel didn't
shoot any scenes together in the eighth
installment of the franchise in fact
when the movie came out it was clear
that the former wrestler was kept far
away from Diesel's character Johnson
went on to star in his own spin-off to
the franchise Hobbs and Shaw borrowing
two characters from Diesel's Fast &
Furious franchise that are specifically
not Dominic Toretto I'm not working with
this guy I've been there done that
Martin Lawrence and Tisha Campbell might
have played a married couple on the
sitcom Martin but things turned bad in a
hurry thanks to some behind-the-scenes
drama Campbell reportedly walked off the
set and quit the Fox sitcom after
hearing stories that Lawrence allegedly
threatened and abused his wife and their
child people reported that when
producers tried to sue for her to get
back to work
she countersued them charging Lawrence
with quote repeated and escalating
sexual harassment sexual battery verbal
abuse and related threats both sides in
the lawsuit reportedly settled out of
court however their days of playing
husband and wife together were over camp
agreed to come back to work and finish
out the last season of the series but
would reportedly only do so if it was
arranged that Lawrence would never be
unset whether at the same time marriages
are tough but it seems that TV marriages
might be even tougher sometimes actors
feud and other times they're made
uncomfortable by their co-stars however
when it comes to neal mcdonough refusing
to film a love scene with actress
virginia madsen
on the ABC series scoundrels religion is
to blame McDonough was reportedly fired
after just days of filming and deadline
notes that what was once called a
casting change was the result of
McDonough who was a Catholic and married
to model Reeve a Robertson refusing to
film love scenes or even kissing scenes
in any film or TV role in fact ABC
should have known better as McDonough's
beliefs were the cause of friction
during his stint on Desperate Housewives
McDonough told The Christian Examiner in
2016
killing people on-screen that's fake
when you're in bed with another woman on
screen guess what
that's real I don't like that kind of
stuff especially now with kids I don't
want to have my kids say hey Dad what
are you doing with that lady on screen
the star often discusses how his beliefs
it cost him roles and work in Hollywood
in fact sticking to his principles on
the set of scoundrels reportedly cost
him a 1 million dollar payday as for
whether or not it's worth it it seems
the star still keeps to his rules today
it's always great for a TV show when art
imitates life and the actors behind a
pair of characters get romantically
involved in real life this was the case
for Gossip Girl stars Penn Badgley and
Blake Lively the couple dated on the
show and they eventually got together in
the real world before Lively married her
Green Lantern co-star Ryan Reynolds in
2012 around the time Badgley and Lively
broke up their characters parted ways
with each other as well prompting many
fans to believe that their offspring
chemistry which informed so much of the
heat between their characters was gone
now that they were no longer smooching
in real life
Badgley kind of confirmed the news
during an appearance on watch what
happens live when the actor was asked
about his best and worst onscreen kiss
best I'll say it was Blake because we
actually had a relationship at the time
right and then and in the worst maybe
Blake after we broke up it turns out the
stars were still keeping their private
lives private for a while before they
informed the cast
Kru they were no longer together it's
unclear how the minds behind the show
reacted but with the chemistry gone and
things awkward for everyone
it's rumored the duo decided it was time
for their characters to cease touching
all together check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you